[Music]
you know I've had a lot of feelings and
thoughts this last week and I wanted to
express it in some way that dealt with
what we do through our art and also the
craft of acting applause erupted
throughout the room at the SAG Awards
Sunday night during david harbors
political and powerful acceptance speech
on behalf of the stranger things cast
we've 1983 Midwestern will repel bullies
we will shelter freaks and outcasts
those who have no home we will get past
the lies we will hunt monsters we will
as per Chief Jim hopper punch some
people in the face when they seek to
destroy life and we will do it all with
soul good horse
we thank you for this responsibility
thank you had you run the speech by your
castmates it sounded like well it looked
like Winona was hearing it for the first
time did it I didn't see her reaction
they're priceless go home and watch it
it's amazing um yeah I actually we were
at dinner the other night and uh it was
Cara and the teens and myself and I was
like guys I want to say this kind of
crazy speech like can I run it by you
and Charlie was like no no now you ruin
it you'll jinx us and that but finally
we beat him Dinda submission and I did
do it for them but it even changed last
night based on the protests that are
going on at the airports and and all
this stuff that's going down I started
to change it some more but they did help
me and they did reassure me that it was
an okay thing to say and that it wasn't
pretentious and you know and that I
could say it so I was very appreciative
of their feedback
what about celebrations tonight you guys
going to be going somewhere to to party
to ring it all in and get out you know
what I keep hearing in an alley that's
what happens after the other side Cortez
oh right I've never been
[Music]
you